[Music]
all right y'all it's time to close out
with something we've done on social
media this is what I'm
[Applause]
liking if you're an animal lover like me
chances are you will do almost anything
to make your fur baby feel like part of
the family my next guest took that to a
whole new level people they're Chicago
mixologist who created a high-end
crafted cocktail for their cat Mr
biscuits non-alcoholic of
course hi I know it's Ty your cocktail
City Instagram exploded over this video
here's my favorite comment though word
to the wise I tried this with my cat and
found him in the corner on the phone
swiping ride on every kitten in a f mile
radius yeah alcohol goggles uh we have
Jess John and Mr biscuits on the line
right now watching on NBC Chicago what's
up
y'all oh my gosh your cat is so cute so
how did your cat learn to like this or
did it like the cat the cocktails right
off the bat yeah so Kelly we're big
cocktail people in our house John and I
actually own a small business here in
Chicago called aged and Infused so we
make a line of allnatural alcohol
infusion kits so we're always drinking
good come happy hour and a few months
ago we were sipping on our martinis and
looked over at this little three-legged
floofy cat Mr biscuits and we were like
we got to get him in on the action so we
went thrifting found the tiniest martini
glass we could find and then John came
up with a little cocktail recipe yeah I
took his favorite treat which is this
disgusting salmon paste and you add a
little water to it shaking over ice and
he absolutely loves it oh my gosh I wish
I weren't allergic cats because I would
fly to your house and I would just
snuggle with Mr biscuits I mean that fur
I want to bury my face and that for oh
my gosh well see you have some new
recipes right oh yeah yeah I've been
playing around with a little bit of tuna
juice and then we garnish it with a
little bit of catnip and he absolutely
loses his mind over it U we call it the
Cosmopolitan and these these cat lovers
are no joke uh people are asking for
more recipes they want to know where we
got the little Shaker and glasses from
so we're actually working on a little
kitty cat cocktail kit that we're going
to sell with our business so people can
make cocktails for I was going to say
that I was like you are missing a giant
opportunity here man we got this that's
amazing can you imagine a kitty bar
anyway it sounds fun and I want to do
one of the voices um anyway thank you so
much Jess and John I'm liking your post
right now but that's not all our season
long partner pilot pin makers of G2 and
the new G2 Edge the go-to pins of the
Kelly Clarkson show love that you're
giving Mr biscuits the time of his life
really um so they're going to be riding
you a check for $1,000 that should help
with some
recipes all the
catnet thank you guys so much I love
your family thank you to all our guests
this hour Bryce Dallas Howard Catherine
O'Hara Desmond me Frank Angel and Wendy
youall have a great name it's not
[Music]
Strang
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home